you know I am not the biggest Sports guy
in the world I did go to a Super Bowl
party I watched about 30 seconds of what
was going on on screen and so
fortunately my producer Mr Davies he is
a big Sports guy he watched it he was
actually texting me the updates he said
oh my gosh you're not going to believe
this that this the other thing so now I
will get to see it and believe it
because seeing is believing here is the
first Super Bowl moment in which I'm
told the U.S Navy sailors were forced to
dress in Pride flag colors during the
national anthem
and screaming
who's brought stripes
oh no oh my goodness
I thought you would just mean in the
stadium you're saying on a ship they had
to put on the pride flag a lot of Navy
jokes opening up here there's an
apocryphal quote from Winston Churchill
which says that Naval tradition is
nothing but rum sodomy in the Lash this
is not going to help the uh the poor
Sailors standing when they're having a
few drinks with people from the other
branches you know that's not going to
help that they got to wear the Press oh
very nice these guys are going out there
they're sacrificing their time they're
serving their country they're risking
their lives and the National Football
League is forcing them to really lean
into a lot of gay jokes
all right next one is Serena Williams
lecturing football players while
butchering Al Pacino's inch by inch
speech
I don't know what to say really
we're in the dark right now
and we can stay here
but we can fight our way back to the
light one inch
at a time the inches we need are
everywhere around us they are in every
break of the game every second on this
team we tear ourselves and everyone
around us to pieces for that image we
claw with our fingernails for that inch
because we know that's going to make the
difference between winning and losing
now I can't make you do it you got to
look at the person next to you now I
think you're gonna see someone who will
go that inch with you because when it
comes down to it you're gonna do the
same for them that's a team ladies and
gentlemen now what are you gonna do
Remy Martin ESOP I love Remy Martin I
love good cognac
I didn't hate that that was fun look was
it the best acting in the world no
generally it's not wise to try to redo
some of the most famous
uh monologues in the history of film
that doesn't usually go over well this
is why
it's usually disappointing when when
actors do to be or not to be to be
everybody already has in his mind
a version of what the best version of to
be or not to be is it's just too famous
no more
and while Any Given Sunday is not Hamlet
that that monologue
an inch you know everybody
that everybody
knows the pachito performance he is a
great actor
with a fingernails
even though sometimes he's very over the
top Serena Williams is not an actress at
all so you're destined to fail in that
but I don't mind that it was I don't
think that was a woke commercial it
wasn't Shilling some crazy left-wing
agenda item it was just it was a a
remake of a scene from a good movie
selling Cognac that's great that's like
the best moment of a Super Bowl I've
seen in years that's football guys
okay number three is the first ever
female flyover uh oh
all women fly over
[Applause]
no
it's not
that's not nice
just waiting for the editors to give me
some sort of is it coincidence that was
the first ever female flyover and now
all of a sudden we've got all of these
UFOs dropping out of the sky all sorts
of accidents and explosions happening in
the air and I I don't know is that a
coincidence
no I don't know I don't know if it is
and number four
the black national anthem
[Music]
well guys just like can this be over
with
in this place it's really sad
I I did see this bit I mentioned it on
the show The Black national anthem it's
just pathetic
one because you remember one probably
one of the most famous Super Bowl
moments ever is Whitney singing the real
national anthem
[Applause]
and it was just sewing it was one of the
greatest performances of that ever at a
sporting event and then you see this
woman that nobody's ever heard of
singing this fake song that's totally
contrived that no one's ever heard that
we all have to it's it's the Juneteenth
of songs we all now have to pretend like
this thing wasn't just made up five
minutes ago and oh it's of course the
black national anthem wolf there's a
black national anthem that means there's
a black nation and if there's a black
there's a national anthem for the black
people and one for the white people and
all the other people are kind of caught
in the middle
well what does that mean we're in one
geographic area so if there's two
Nations here that either means that
we're going to have to partition like
India and Pakistan or we're going to
have a race war I mean that's what the
libs are calling for they're saying we
got all right we got two nations in one
spot have at it Go Go BLM please
it's egging on white supremacists you
know feds trying to get crazy white
people to have attacks and things like
that so that's it doesn't end well is
all I'm saying this is does not the game
that the libs are playing right now does
not end very well for anybody okay final
moment the NFL's female flag football
player just can't be stopped I am here
with world champion
[Music]
man I'm trying to lock down the
perimeter and you worried about sauce
it's all about the sauce
[Music]
she got moves
oops
[Music]
oh boy I was gonna say that the worst
pandering of all of these moments was
the black national anthem certainly the
most dangerous certainly
the darkest one
but
this is the most ridiculous one the the
flag football thing it it's because the
executives doing the show they said well
we've got a we've we've been really
pro-gay we've hyped up all the race
stuff the whole time but in the end zone
it said end racism that'll get them guys
okay wow racism owned solved
but this is the most to say okay we need
some more women stuff we've we had them
fly the Jets over
we need some more woman stuff so women
obviously can't play football against
men they'll die instantly so okay we'll
have them do flag football the game that
you play when you're 10 years old and
we'll try to make that seem really cool
and and we'll make it seem like no one
can catch her and take the flag but of
course any man who has ever played
football for more than a week could very
easily beat her at this probably even
men who've played for less than a week
these men are much faster than women
much much much faster and much bigger
than women and they just they just grab
her they just take it it wouldn't be
hard at all that's why they had to
choreograph this whole dance with the
giant bird going down the escalator
that's that's why it had to be pretend
because if it were real it would not
have lasted very long that's that I
think the flag football that takes the
cake for the most absurd least credible
part of an otherwise pandering Super
Bowl glad I didn't watch pretty much any
of the game
[Music]
foreign